I wish I did this seven years ago I wish
you got to see the last seven years
every minute every day always forever
oh and five without mellowness here it's
good yes this pipe in though we're
better off without my lawyer
hopefully this version mellow past
Houston Oklahoma City fella yeah you're
there for both
oh no I was we were both already
three minutes for me okay no publicity
but whoever you guys Deemas the five to
seven people that need to know first is
something that is something that I think
we can do today like I don't think at
this point those and you telling them
and they're your friends is for you to
tell them today
unless I'm wrong I mean I'm kind of
shooting the [ __ ] here you know honey no
bad Higgins our business partner the
kind of drove former president the debts
drove the transaction for Steve Ross
owner to dolphins because he works with
them now to ivy piece of vaynermedia and
is my partner in vayner/rse um best dude
brother hello well how are you I am
quite well thank you so I'm doing well
how are you good
great very good my major concern as ever
is keeping your answers as full as
possible yes in this new system exactly
yep make sense be keeping all the things
that are in the book without being a
repetition of the book being you know I
think I think it's right I think the
thing we did with the bullet points I
think reading them putting couple of all
points lends it to more depth less
hyperbole and so I think I think that
will work here we keep on doing yeah the
LED is not monetized Ram it's free
content to teach people the way that I
would learn which is I wouldn't learn by
reading I would learn by watching
and so the askgaryvee show is very you
know kind of prescription kind of like
here's the direct answer I've been very
happy reading the comments of dailyvee
for the people that are built like me
which is like I just learned something
and for 90% of you you didn't see it but
for the 10% that learned the way I do
they picked up on a cadence or way I
said it or how I done it or it's really
really cool it's really cool to make a
show that would have helped the 16 year
old me and that's what the led is for me
like that's how I would have learned I'd
learn by watching I learned by watching
everybody and we're going really that's
why we're pushing it's so hard
email subject line BAM derecho talks
about that right like that was one
little thing that I may have never
gotten to in a scary or honestly there's
been like three or four people that
emailed me that are pretty big in the
game and they said here's the weirdest
thing I've learned from you you're
actually nice to people like when you're
like at the airport or your driver like
somebody in the elevator and like I
thought I was a big shot and I wasn't as
nice and you're way bigger than me and I
kind of punched me in the gut I know
that you were excited about that because
you know how I rolled in you were
excited I knew that like I knew like
without even knowing I'd be the first
couple guarantees we're going to have
that they'll knees because I was like I
know d-roc wants the world to know that
nice guy all right and here's his
question you just hear it and then
wallet while you're hearing that take a
look at your long hair yes long and W
you gotta include Gone with the Wind you
gotta break got it hey guys what's up -
draymond Green four for the Golden State
Warriors and I am super excited about
reading the next ten questions in the
askgaryvee book to you thanks a lot for
having me you are much appreciated
how do I create interesting content for
a boring product or a stale industry I'm
gonna read the first part because that
has to be there
got it a white lawyer defends a black
man in a small southern town a spoiled
rich girl gets married three times and
survives the Civil War boy meets girl
recognize any of these shave down to the
core To Kill a Mockingbird Gone with the
Wind and Romeo and Juliet sound pretty
damn boring they're loud they're lasting
power lies in fresh imaginative daring
surprising storytelling of their
creators there is no boring if you tell
the right story you tell the story right
there is no boring if you tell your
story right what really gets me excited
about this question is just living my
life for so many years people came up to
me and said Gary you're so lucky though
especially with crush it and as my brand
was Bill you're so lucky Gary you've
wine that's an interesting category
that's why you were successful what you
know if you know me that pissed me off
to no end because I wanted to remind
people that before me really before me
wine was held in a very esteemed place
in the US people talk down to people
about it if anything people were
intimidated about wine yeah there was a
small subset normally in the affluent
world of people that were intrigued by
but the people that I was reaching and
people that were getting excited about
wine and get excited about me
these are beer drinkers these are 23
year old dudes these were 31 year old
females that have never been exposed to
the wine world they thought about wine
three times a year Thanksgiving this
that and the other thing it wasn't that
interesting it's just I created interest
around it and if you look back if you
look at Jim Cramer you know is is that
really interesting is Wall Street
interesting to people that don't care
about making money on Wall Street the
answer's no and I can break down
everything including things that we've
accepted like sports and music by the
way I'm not that interested in music but
Casey Kasem in the morning as a kid on
radio got me excited about it if you
know how to story tell especially if you
have two things listen to me and listen
to me good and this is a very very
important part of this audio book if you
have passion like you really love it
like you really love it and because a
lot of you love a lot of things and you
have expertise if you really know it
everybody knew I had passion with Wine
Library TV what everybody forgot is the
day I started that show I've been in
that industry for more than half my life
that at 14 15 16 and 17 years old before
I was 30 when I started the show I was
reading The Wine Spectator becoming
educated that from 21 to 30 I was
tasting and drinking 50 wines a day
buying for one of the biggest companies
in the country becoming deeply educated
so when I had all my charisma and I was
excited I could also have the chops for
the people that actually cared about
learning if you have those two things
you can win whether you're building jet
engines if you're doing carpeting I'm
looking at the carpet right now as I
read this I'm bored as Helles car with
carpets but I promise you if you're
listening right now and you are
passionate about carpets you know
interior design if you don't think that
you can make a snapchat or Instagram or
YouTube show that explodes your carpet
business well then you're not paying
attention to what's happened over the
last 10 years and more importantly
what's going to happen over the next 10
years
there is absolutely no boring product if
you're actually in business let me say
that again
there is absolutely no boring product if
you're actually in business if people
are buying it they have an interest
maybe it's not the most interesting
thing in the world they have an interest
about saving money on it using it
properly
it may be a utility not an entertainment
but if you're lucky enough to be selling
a utility something people need and if
you can just add a little bit of
entertainment then you've got gold that
was awesome that was great thank you
dear ah I want that good I want that
whole thing so pumped you here I want
that whole thing that's gonna give depth
that's like the best answer I gave on
this on this damn book so far no going
back the shot yeah I'm gonna make today
levy what's going on - did the franchise
you're on TV 11
I love it yeah yeah it was so weird um
okay so this is first it's a beast only
one on there huh okay you know it's
funny it's 954 in the in the evening and
first mykes now following me around
you'll be seeing Mike a lot more because
we're on a 12-week are we gonna 12-week
Mike they're home fat loss 12-week fat
loss gonna get gnarly really cut up so
that should be fun so to be more Mike on
the daily me show but figuring that this
episode is uh is a little tricky to
create a narrative I was even about led
rock maybe we don't even run an episode
on days where there's like not an exact
thing but uh I think later this we'll
see how it goes I feel like this is my
opportunity to like do rants like
wonders episodes that you know alright
that's right I I love on its door I'll
try to give you some more like who look
through okay you're back
oh look dear och I got your back I hate
that we care about lighting that 100
percent way and your last one and before
it turned an exam but you know what I
mean 100 I think there's a deal to be
done yes because I think there's a
discount for me cuz I wouldn't do it
otherwise and I'm hoping in that
discount you guys get excited that's
what I think yeah alright keep talking
yah where my girl right here
Oh with you with a right what is it
someone right now slack officially for
the state what's up everybody this is
Gary Vaynerchuk your CEO unlike normal
times where I stick around and kind of
pander to whatever the other person has
to say about this I'm leaving because I
think Alex can handle this mainly cuz
most of you don't know who he is
that's why I'm here to make you realize
it's a vaynermedia video Alex take it
away alright thanks for ya are you want
earbuds you know well yeah then you know
Mike okay
that's right keep playing final set go
fast cool so Facebook stock exploded
after our earnings I haven't read it yet
but I'm excited about that I will end up
being cooked historically correct on
Facebook for sure snapchat will follow
that as well we've been talking a lot
about those things
re Marcus I think what we need to do is
get a lot more information here which
I'll let you guys do and get more of
what the KPIs are or they just you know
it's a general awareness engagement like
I this part I think I'm very comfortable
too for people that are on the call and
then and then kind of use me as the
backstop to like the production of video
costs against this to like drive down
the overhead so we can come into an
attractive price for bread you know
everyone walks in in the morning TMZ
two hours ago something at the Newseum
what and you build pillars that give you
you got to build pillars that give you
permission to go there like if you have
a weekly podcast you can go there yes
looks like someone on doors you can't
just tweet it off inside of my jobs to
do the podcast instead of my jobs to
think about
get out before that's right today
Bellwood yeah that's exactly right they
basically allocated human reason well
they weren't even different make sure
they're okay have an entire P&L they're
trying to run the thing as a profit
Center which is right cheers to good
health good health guys had some great
client meetings in the last couple days
tomorrow's an intense day flying in
flying out to Tennessee
so that should be a pretty interesting
day four hour delay this morning ah
because of fog in Knoxville and then my
pilot appendicitis we finally took off
and then the fog didn't clear Knoxville
so we had to land in Chattanooga so now
I'm just gonna sit in the Chattanooga
Airport do the 90-minute call with the
client has been amazing thank you for
that Dave and I'm going right back in
the plane and fly back you know
9:54 p.m. now going to another meeting I
was intrigued by the first three or four
episodes of people like quantifying like
how hard I work or putting in the hours
this has been unbelievably interesting
back to the rant I did in the in the in
the booth 3 in my book I realized what
dailyvee and I'm just reading all the
comments for episode 10 instead of
jockeying and politicking and pondering
and posturing and debating for three to
four months we're just a duo now now
when you're in do mode and get done it's
fun that we're producing a piece of
content that allows people to learn in a
different way you know it's unbelievable
that I've been writing books and doing
keynotes and making videos and putting
out a hundred seventy five episodes an
interview after interview I'm going to
must be thousands of videos now on
YouTube of me talking about the hustle
I guess I'm intrigued that I'm really
speaking to you guys now all these other
personalities have created a scenario
where I don't think you guys believe
anymore and I think what dailyvee is
doing and I'd like to challenge my
contemporaries thought leaders people
that write books people that want to
sell seminars and courses and monthly
retainers to audiences I challenge them
I challenge you guys to put out your
daily B's I think this is exciting I
think I think proving to the market I
mean I'm excited that the rock has to
now and you know what I like the
timestamp on snapchat too because I get
to really prove it I guess can you can
put a snapchat and anything I mean you
can put a timestamp with anything but it
is dark uh you know I'm excited that
like like what time we start today 6:15
what's up we started 6:15 today right
yes yeah yeah yes it's me like you know
I'm excited about the 5:45 wake up and
the and the 10:00 I was excited cuz me
and AJ ended up a little early like by
10:15 starting for my next meeting I
didn't realize that people thought it
wasn't true and that's the truth and
that's the truth for so many of you
watch oh now didn't think it was true
you didn't think was true that they were
15 16 hours a day you thought they were
hyperbolized and they were eight or nine
you didn't realize every minute was
something you didn't realize that it's
every day always forever and and not
that this is for everybody but it speaks
to it surely has eliminated the luck
thing and what I don't think people
realize is this has been going on every
day for the last seven years at this
pace every day every single day 2,000
days in a row just you know pounding and
grinding and hustling and the client to
page a and i strategizing to investment
opportunity coming up right now
you know vetting you know what do you
think all these answers come from you
think they come from kicks and giggles
either gum sitting for an hour on the
beach listen to somebody else's podcast
and we're entertaining because I know
whose work encouraged I know who's
regurgitating my [ __ ] I know who you are
I watch it I get it I understand and I
watch it I get and understand because
I'm putting the work because in between
Wendy rocks looking for b-roll right now
I'm on my phone I'm answering I'm
reading I'm figuring out I'm consuming
the market and so the nice feeling is I
thought some of this stuff that I'm
feeling over the last three weeks with
daily B would happen in my 60s and 70s
and 80s when the results would just
prove out but I didn't realize the power
of the storytelling of what this is
going to do first I was probably weirdly
early on everybody said this on the show
disappointed that people are so
surprised but now I'm excited because
there's a separation but this is a lab
for me and I like it I like that people
are starting to realize I'm different
mainly because it's selfish for me but
it also allows people to not be
disappointed one of the most powerful
things that are going on right now is
how many people like okay I shouldn't be
having Gary type results because I'm
putting in half the work I mean we're
you know what six seemed to work out
it worked on our 13 14 15 like course if
you're going to work seven hours oh by
the way I didn't take an hour lunch no
by the way I didn't take 15 minutes to
watch some [ __ ] it'll better late
and have a 22 minute talk then why go in
and take a 5 p.m. beer ever ever not
today not for the next seven thousand
episodes of daily because right now you
didn't believe it at all and right now
it's going 10 or 11 episodes but you
know God willing we'll get old you up
but like I wish it was 7 years ago I
wish you got to see the last 7 years
every minute every day oh I record I
know you do we know Mike our ID I get it
listen it's become for the heart it's
all okay